i used to [ __ ] hate public speaking
like in school it was
oh me too the worst thing and which was
weird because
i used to be part of my school's
debating team like we had like a
debating team
and you know it was like groups of three
and you usually go against other schools
about whatever the [ __ ] it was yeah we
do not have this in the uk i don't think
unless you're in oxford cambridge i
don't think so
i definitely didn't have this where i
grew up well yeah i mean it was
literally just the three of us
and so i was i decided to join that
because i realized how much i [ __ ]
hated public speaking
and how bad i was just speaking in
general so i was like
how old are you and you decided to do
this this was in actually this no this
was in elementary school so this is like
god damn sixth grade so like eleven
twelve-year-old jerry's like you know
what i have a deficiency i would like to
improve
yeah i'm going to do that you know you
know what like watching all those like
squeaker family videos man i was just
like
i need to prove my voice and i don't
want to sound like alvin
so basically yeah so i joined this
debating team um
and of course like i was in it for like
two years but
i was still nervous as [ __ ] like i was
very fiddly and kind of
i had this really bad habit of swaying
as i talked yeah yeah like you don't
realize how many subconscious things you
do until you get filmed
yeah why you should record yourself yeah
no and that and that's what we did all
right so my parents
sometimes would come to these debating
things with other schools
and of course they would record it just
for memory's sake and
of course i'd be forced to watch it
during our family [ __ ]
you know family videos on the 4k monitor
exactly
if i watch back on i'll be like jesus
christ i look like
[ __ ] schizophrenic patient
so my conclusion is yeah but you were 12
dude i probably [ __ ] my pants at that
situation no but
all the other like schools we went up
against yes we're just [ __ ]
shot as [ __ ] yes yes your honor let me
let me defend myself and my and my
colleagues right here is like yeah
and meanwhile i'm just like you have a
point
but no it was that level
it was [ __ ] horrible but then so i
i tried to use that skill when i first
started doing youtube
yeah but of course like everyone's first
youtube videos it's [ __ ]
it [ __ ] sucks and you know i had that
i still have this problem to this day
where i say like and you know way too
much
yeah and yeah people on trash taste the
point of that being like
yeah take a shot every time joyce is
like or you know
and you'll be dead in the first five
minutes you have like a lot of
like everyone subconsciously has a lot
of filler words that you don't
normally hear yourself saying because
it's filler words when you say it you
kind of like
fill in the gap yourself and there are
times when i say like a lot and then
there are times when i just
swear a lot as well yeah it's either
like you know or [ __ ]
but also i'm sitting there right you
know i'm a viewer right
who am i to be like your company just
like too much you know
as if they as if they have like the most
immaculate speech
it's like do you go around not saying
the word like ever in your speech
like with any other people like i don't
know i guess it's because uh
is it i don't know i i don't get it
because i i i understand
that everyone has [ __ ] that they do yeah
they might want to change
but there's something in my eye
why do you need to feel the need to like
tell people i guess wow there's really
something
yeah you're
you know youtube videos fixing your
speech
yeah because i feel like when when
people see when people see doing stuff
on youtube nowadays it's like the
expectation is that
for some reason the expectation is they
must know what they're doing they're
professionals right right
and it's really weird because i remember
the first time i felt this
was when i started to get asked to do
like panels and stuff
oh and i was thinking to myself i've
never been good at public speaking my
entire [ __ ] life and just because
i have this audience this virtual
audience on youtube like conventions and
stuff especially expect you to like
being like a top-tier panelist and stuff
i'm just like
this is a skill i had to like learn
trial by fire you know what i mean
because my first few panels were [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i felt like [ __ ] because i was
[ __ ] at public speaking but because you
were forced to be put
to put they forced you to be put in that
situation you just had to learn it on
the fly
but i do find it funny that just because
we're on youtube people do have this
expectation of just like
yeah they must be really confident and
have this professional kind of [ __ ]
background
otherwise how would they get all these
subs right like you couldn't talk
probably and they seem to forget that
we all started in the same place making
videos in our uni bedroom or our parents
bedroom
parent's basement or something like that
in my case it's a little bit
different because i hated public
speaking but i was always okay in front
of large crowds
which is weird you think it's kind of
character isn't that literally public
speaking
speaking if it's not no he's no that's
the thing though it's like when i was
doing the debating team stuff
the most we would ever talk in front of
was maybe 30 people
yeah right and there's some weird it's
really counterintuitive but
a lot of the times i'm more nervous in
front of a small crowd
than i am alive i think it's more
intimate right like it's
if you have to do it in front of people
you know especially yeah i think it's a
lot harder
because i've done like because i used to
do uh classical piano
and i've played live at like the sydney
opera house once in front of like a
thousand people oh [ __ ]
dropping that like yeah
so yeah so basically i used to do like
music like properly yeah um
and i got the chance to perform at the
sydney opera house in front of like a
thousand people
14 15. wow um and
yeah it was just like yeah you're
playing at the opera house i'm like
like the opera house that's the asian
parents dream right yeah
my mom has never been more proud of me
that's never coming off the fridge for
sure
did your mum [ __ ] film it and then
like frame it and then frame it then
put in like the safe and stuff yeah yeah
of course you did of course
i think one thing that really helped me
realize that should start not giving a
[ __ ] is that uh
and this is just in general life as well
is that like i think i remember who told
me this they were like everyone is
always
way more worried about themselves than
they ever are about you oh yeah and so
like
if you just think about it like that and
think about how you think about it when
someone is public speaking
i don't [ __ ] care if they're [ __ ] i'm
just most of the time i'm just sitting
there anyway
like they can just say anything and i'll
probably be like oh cool yeah all right
like unless they like literally [ __ ]
their pants on stage i'm not gonna think
anything bad of them right right
so if you go into that mindset of okay
i'm gonna talk in front of these people
uh none of them care really [ __ ] it how
can i [ __ ] this up i
can't be terrible yeah but speech i feel
is a little bit different because even
if you do [ __ ] up
you can very quickly try and fix it
right it's a little bit different when
you're
playing solo piano in front of a crowd
now dude jazz
just dude it's not classical anymore
it's jazz
when you go on stage do you remember the
stuff you do and the stuff you say
because i don't remember that [ __ ] like
like because sometimes
do you still get nerves when you have
like a big panel or a big event anymore
no
no i get nerves right up until i'm on
stage
same here same thing so like on the like
up the stairs going onto the stage i'm
[ __ ] nervous
it's the anticipation yeah it's just
like i just want to get this over with
you know what i mean i just want to get
on stage and just do my [ __ ] yeah i mean
the reason why is because you know if
you're doing a debate thing
no one cares about who you are right
yeah yeah but when it's your your panel
right
all the people come for you yeah yeah so
i could sit there and salt them
for 20 minutes they would be like damn
connor's exactly like he is on camera
hell yeah it's just as much